après cette chanson j'espère que je
dirai à faire conclut et sorgho et non
mais redescend
non mais justement aller à à ne pas
commencer
la formation
son latin
quand je la regarde elle me rend fou
[Musique]
donc
mon coeur n'a plus aucun 0
on va on va on va créer un secret allez
on va le dire tu sais que c'est on en
parle il ya un instant c'est vrai qu'il
ya deux ans j'avais très envie que tu
viennes sur s'est vite voilà on était on
était en valeur on s'était un peu
austère pauvre nifle est sur une très
bonne idée
ouais vous voulez que tu refasses elle a
tout essayé sur ces 8 voilà animé par
sophie davant et je vous jure c'est vrai
ya deux ans il ya deux ans donne on a 2
ans 1 mais quand sur quel dans la
semaine à quel moment là bas on aurait
trouvé je vais vous dire pour les bons
programmes ya toujours de la place
exacte mais parce que parce que je peux
je suis moi je peux le faire s'il n'y a
pas de fait mais c'est sophie n'est pas
dispo mais c'est vous seriez très bien
dans une autre c'est un excellent
animateur match mais on est passé en
voyant chef de bande il est très fort
c'est fait voilà c'est fait vous allez
voir tirer addition c'est lui qu'elle
concerne un petit partout
et sera tout m'est ago
ce portrait des slips
quand groupe
ah ouais ouais je la kiffe sophie
c'était stéphane bern qui devait faire
l'émission débute oui et lui la passion
petit délire et ceni brocante
stéphane bern trente deux après-midis
égalera sera sec avec l'histoire le
patrimoine c'est beaucoup ce sera envie
de s'essayer à d'autres sujets devenus
mais ce qui est dommage c'est qu'on l'a
dit qu'il avait refusé parce qu'ils
trouvent que le projet était nul alors
que c'est pas du tout pas du tout non
c'est pas du tout la raison par les
animaux exactement
lui voulait absolument l'autre des
animaux balader prochaine ils font des
animaux avec la brocante
alors je t'emmènerai
à chat
sophie davant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
élève ton corps partout
alors qu'elle présentait la météo ce
offerte un jeu de mots assise et j'ai
pas fait exprès du tout je suis prêt oui
c'était très drôle ça roger zabel qui a
animé le programme à l'époque on l'a
déjà vu ça mais on ne s'en lasse pas
sophie arrêtez vous cachez pas on adore
regarder c'est parti c'est l'hiver qui
approche maintenant alors sophie serait
ce parce qu'on peut faire qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire dans cette histoire
devient t'encule ans je vous dirai plus
fort il nous ressert très beau encore
aujourd'hui est expliqué et je vais y
aller ça c'est même pas un pari mais il
faut expliquer moi j'étais là depuis
trois semaines j'étais pigiste une
petite qui débutait qui se lever tous
les jours à 4h du matin pour être la
leur et roger faisait des blagues pour
l'émission et donc il raconte l'histoire
des hussards et des uhlans qui sont
antagonistes de père en fils qui peuvent
pas se voir et alors il raconte ça au
maquillage et d'à peine réveillé et il
est midi ben voilà c'est un nul en c1
c'est à us are fatigué qui rencontra une
leçon dans sa base en peuvent plus y
sont désabusés et le lys à radio lantus
et moi en tant qu sarr on dirait que on
dirait que je t'aurais pas vu et on
arrête de se taper dessus je t'ai pas
vue et le turban t'encule ans je t'ai
pas vu non plus c'était la blague
d'audit
il n'ya rien à comprendre et il commence
l'antenne il démarre l'antenne à 6h30 du
matin en disant en tant que star bonjour
madame tout le monde se marre et je
l'attends c'était quoi la bac et donc je
commençais météo je les entends qu
lançant réaliser ce que je dis cela en
dit ah oui boys et donc je vois que
c'est pas drôle du tout r je vois coran
gmr enfoncé dans son fauteuil
sinon c'est pas possible elle n'a pas
dit l'a pas dit
en avant
sophie davant
ce matin
sont pas bien fait caca nous
pour sophie davant
ça
si l'avant je t'aime
dans ce jeu
[Applaudissements]